hey guys so we just got a package in the
mail today ah some manga that goes in
ordered so let's let's open the package
and see what's up here so this is the
package guys from amazon.ca and i just
ordered honey and clover vol.1 the manga
I'm getting more into manga and you know
i love the anime yeah and it's shojo
beat manga so just in case you're
wondering and the other thing is orange
which is also shoujo so I love me some
shoujo you'll be getting a whole video
on how much I love shoujo this guy loves
this show Joe anyways that's not like
what what like caught our attention
right away what our attention was this
yeah if you guys can see that apparently
uh anime sucks bro with two exclamation
marks all capital bros so this guy's
serious and at least at least this anime
hater has a proper grammar because he
put a comma after the anime sucks yeah
but like literally we got this package
at our door on the other day and someone
actually wrote anime sucks pro on it so
we don't know if it was someone at
amazon or so i'm guessing a packager
like was just packing it recognized
anime and for some reason he he dislikes
and i don't know if there's like
girlfriend broke up with him to be with
a guy likes anime I don't let that said
yeah like I don't know we don't know if
it was someone at amazon we don't know
if it was someone in the delivery
service whatever but you know it's maybe
the guy was just trying to be funny it's
cool we don't think that personally we
don't to get anyone in trouble relax but
I really got me thinking man you got me
thinking that there seems to be a lot of
anime hate out there these days and I
like so when we comment on other YouTube
videos with our account because we have
a anime profile picture and an anime
username oftentimes even if it's a video
does not to do with anime and we just
comment and our comment is not a dude
anime a bunch of people just start
applying saying oh weeb you're such a
weeb your total weeaboo your nerd all
this kind of stuff just like out of
nowhere for no reason so it does scene I
don't know if you if you have the same
kind of feelings but I feel like ever
since Allah a few years back anime has
beginning more and more mainstream apart
from the west with like attack on titan
and all that kind of stuff there see
I like a backlash against anime by
certain segments of people who just
don't want to get into it and then
they're kind of one of bash people who
like it so what do you think goes in
yeah I think there's a lot of like
misconceptions right there isn't anime
is people don't know what to talk about
I'm gonna do pretty soon like a anime
what is it and deal with the
misconceptions about it oh that's a good
idea yeah I'm going to be doing that
suit but just the idea that people
people hated people think it's childish
people think it's like cartoons right so
it be associated with stuff that it's
not Anna me like there's if you go to
the chapters or something you'll see
manga 14 16 plus and then you'll see a
whole different section for manga in
general for like adults and stuff and
like honey and clover and orange for
example and death note and stuff are all
in the adult section right so this is a
medium not not like genre-specific it's
not all childish so I feel like that's
where a lot of that a chick comes from
just misconceptions and you know like
people need to realize that to cool
people like us you know love anime yeah
that's like you know that's that's the
new cool [ __ ] it's like enemies for kids
bro like that's cartoons man like get a
job bro so I mean I I love anime i rep
it i rep it uh everywhere i go and i
just love those conversations of just
finding someone who likes anime you can
literally have like just stop hour-long
conversation with a stranger just
because you guys like anime can talk
about your favorites what you like we
didn't like you know that's beautiful to
me and I feel like some people you know
maybe it's also a bit it's on it's
unknown and that's why they also hate it
and they just associate being childish
but man like growing up when was wearing
a su and watching documentaries nah man
I'm not about that yeah we're not
growing up you yeah but no I feel like
someone who things in enemies for kids
obviously hasn't seen something like Al
Qaeda or ghost in the shell or grave of
the fireflies past right like these
these are not children's cartoons but
there's still some misconceptions there
i guess and i think
it's like on YouTube sometimes you just
have haters for the sake of hating too
so we gotta say I think a lot of it is
that and just like they know how
passionate we are about anime so I feel
like that's just for that maybe they're
like just like me i'm not that
passionate about anything man I'd to
like destroy their passion everyone is
jealous of anime fans that's what I
wanna that's the whole point of this
video we're the best yeah yeah I think
we could just end it right there like
that's the conclusion you can hate but
we're the best alright guys let us know
what you think about us being the best
and about anime hate in general like do
you get it even on youtube in real life
people just misunderstanding what it's
all about and until next time see you
space cowboys
you